each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
ok the next week speaker is Professor
Punk agility he is the director of
triple iit-delhi and he is also the
founder of triple iit-delhi and prior to
that he was at iit delhi and then he and
i think before that he was at iit kanpur
and his area is mainly in the area of
software engineering he was a head of
the department in Kanpur and he was a
professor at assistant professor
University of Maryland before moving
back to India I professor gelati to come
and deliver his talk and I request all
of you to maintain silence okay good
morning everyone I know you're getting
restless perhaps close to lunchtime
without a short break so let me start
with this in Delhi there is a very close
to my house there is a very favorite
restaurant I have for south indian food
called Saudi just ten by ten few tables
and every now and then I go there for my
favorite he has a South Indian platter
where there is you get russum you start
with one Italy when what aa little those
are
and three other things so I thought I'm
coming too hard or south india so i've
organized my talk like a platter will
give you a little lesson will give you 1
i'd leave will give you a little gutter
and hopefully you'll catch one of these
you like one of these maybe all of it so
let me start with maybe problem so I one
slide I'm going to first talk about my
Institute this is really what I think
and dream about now and I want to share
this as Rick mentioned I'm actually
employee number 001 off the entire
Institute so when we started there is
nothing but me but so I want to just
take a couple of minutes to share with
you I'm hoping that in a couple of years
will be as large as this crowd with us
distinguished people as we have here but
we started in 2008 it's a very research
focused Institute with very strong focus
on PG programs as well as undergraduate
programs right so we have now 32 faculty
because it's a research institution
every faculty member is expected is is a
PhD from one from finest places across
the world and what I also want to share
with you is that we have about 400 be
take students about 100 M Tech students
and we have 40 PhD students about one of
the larger PhD programs and I understand
we have one PhD student from qualms with
our Institute of Technology and every
now and then when I talked to him in the
earlier so how you guys doing I think
he's the one who gives the craziest
answer he says sir I'm in heaven so I
don't know what hear what to mean by
that whether we are really killing him
or whether he's really enjoying it but
he seems to be really enjoying it so if
any of you are interested get excited by
all these talks and what Microsoft is
presenting get excited about doing
research as a courier talk to me there
are two PhD students who will be giving
their posters and come join us so that's
my little less or more pop them about
the Institute
so what is this talk about the main talk
the for which we have the title so most
of you will start your career most of
you perhaps we'll go and join as
engineers and we are talking from this
side mostly as researchers and
researchers and engineers have often
been different communities interacting
but not quite as much as I think they
should but what I want to talk about is
that software engineers the engineers
that job that you do can also engage in
research small research but you can
engage in research now give you multiple
examples of that from my from my own
experience so I'll draw upon my personal
experience having spent interacted
various companies to illustrate the
point that engaging with engineers
particularly if you have researchers
also around can be really fruitful to do
research as well right so that's that's
the that's the main that's the reason
and the topic of this talk so so let me
take since I'm going to draw upon my
personal experience let me take a couple
of sides to just tell you about a little
personal journey relevant to this so my
PhD was not in software engineering from
urbana-champaign but I shifted to when I
joined the university of mainland which
was very strong in software and
everything I shifted to that because I
plan to return to India and I figured at
that time as it turns out correctly in
hindsight that software engineering is
going to become very very important for
India as the time has shown and so I
moved completely to software engineering
in 90s and wrote a textbook about it so
perhaps many of you might have studied
this subject from that book so they are
there some students who studied the
software engineering from a book that
I've written any students all right not
too many now too many all right so looks
like anna university doesn't like my
book that much but that's all right i
took two sabbaticals while being a
faculty member two years I spent in
Infosys as wise
and I spent a year and a half in
microsoft in redmond so let me tell you
a little bit about both of these as to
what I did so in emphasis I went there
with a line responsibility a manager as
vice president quality to head the
quality department it has a very very
functional responsibility it is not
supposed to be doing research or any
such thing there right but as part of
the job and part of what we were doing
because we had to talk to ingenious
about this is how you're supposed to do
good software this is how you should
architect it this is how you should test
it I talked to engage with hundreds of
engineers and project managers there in
two years I was there but look at the
academic output the output that people
like us look at the academic output was
a few good papers I think maybe four or
five that came out research papers that
came out of my two years there at least
one PhD problem that I identified while
I was there I took it back to iit kanpur
and then we had a PhD come out of it
problem originated from my world there
you know too I wrote two books which
were written published by addison wesley
actually they became quite popular
translated in chinese etcetera official
with some royalties from chinese coming
on on to this and there's various other
impacts personally I had a wonderful
time I think I grew more these two years
than any other two years when a case the
main point I want to show is that I did
reasonably good academic work while
actually having completely aligned
responsibilities with no research
component in it now the second sting
Microsoft actually went as a visiting
researcher but in in Windows group not
in microsoft research just to point out
it was in again the product group as it
turned out the boss change within a few
weeks you know big companies have
reorganizations and I found suddenly
that I don't have a boss so the fellow
moved since I was a small guy coming
from you know individual coming
somewhere in India nobody sort of
figured out who should I be attached to
so I was unattached so I went around and
met with a lot of people right and I was
really concerned that no one should end
up saying that hey look this guy this
professor came from IIT Kanpur and just
you know spent a year goofing off and
didn't do anything so I was very
concerned about that so I would just go
around and meet what are you guys doing
what is your problem etcetera etcetera
as it turns out in that short while I I
probably interacted most of the major
major group certainly windows was the
home but I talked to all of these people
from office sequel server corporate etc
again the academic knowledge if you you
see gained five papers came out of it
five different co-authors only one of
them from Microsoft Research I think
other for fiber all people in this
product groups and all these I can say
now was working sabbatical hours which
means you don't work more than five six
hours a day very luxury right nobody has
that luxury I don't have it now you guys
are certainly not going to have it in
your jobs if you're thinking of that
forget about that so why am I am I
telling you about this it's not to just
tell that look as a researcher you can
and as a faculty member you can have a
fun life as well you can write books you
can write papers you can travel work in
different organizations that's also side
goal if you want to be researcher you
can also enjoy some of these kinds of
things but there is the main point I
want to drive home here and the main
first point is that you can find
research problems in most situations if
you are looking for it I get so many
mails from students saying sir I'm doing
my PhD or I want to do a project can you
tell me your problem to work on I think
that's a very dip it is in one sense of
very hard problem but I am saying that
you can find problems if you look for it
and I think these two stints I have
shown without having researched really
as a main focus one
able to find out and the other thing is
that most of us will tell you and you
will see and when we talk about it will
position the research problem that we
are working on and then pose a solution
and show how the solution is good that's
how almost all research talks are there
it leads us to think and indeed that's
how often research works that you do
identify the problem first and you sort
of solve it but what the other lesson
I've learned is the alternative is also
very effective that is you don't have a
big research problem you sort of go and
solve some problems and then see what is
the knowledge coming out and generalize
it certainly at infosys there is no such
concept of me trying to solve some
research problem we did things we found
out interesting things we did and we
generalize it and converted to visit I
think this is also a viable way of doing
research it probably wouldn't lead to
big research but good research can
commander right and the third which is
really type engaged with the title of
the talk both of these are shown that
whatever I was able to do was really
because of engaging with practitioners I
couldn't have done it sitting in my
office either infosys of Microsoft so
engaging with practitioners is important
so if you are going to be a practitioner
in some sense this can give you a sense
or that you can participate in research
in small ways while being a practitioner
would help if you have somebody some
researcher to help you along right now I
want to drive home this point in another
way this is from personal experience but
I want to drive home this point from a
little bit more sort of perspective
maybe slightly meta perspective so I
suspect many of you will end up as a
soft as software engineer in some
company so what is the job of software
engineer if you get some interesting
project where you're going to write some
code then typically the job of your job
will be to develop some software and the
interesting thing
no there is an engineer does not have
total freedom you have to develop
software within some costs within some
time with some quality that's
fundamentally engineering you build
solutions using knowledge within cost
schedule and quality there's some other
parameters as you like that's the nature
of engineering so has to work in that
and has to be predictable you can't have
unpredictable engineering let me write
this let me develop this and we will see
how it turns out let's build a bridge
and see whether it's going to work out
or whether it's going to fall or not you
can't do that so very predictable now
what is engineering software engineering
researcher what is his job his or her
job if this is what software engineer is
doing what is the job of software
engineering researcher now as I
understand people can debate on that I
think the software engineering
researcher not in general software
engineering researcher the goal is
eventually to evolve methods tools what
have you to help software engineer doing
his or her job with in Costigan's
quality and so that's the job or
software engineering center so the
researcher is creating new knowledge new
tools etc which the engineer then uses
to do his or her work right that's
that's the relationship so it shows here
so that's the relationship software
engineering practice much much bigger
people I mean in India we know what
about 300,000 3 lakh or is it three
million I forget or two million whatever
two million we have two million odd
software engineers large population of
engineers who are writing code testing
code maintaining code all this with
predictability etcetera on the other
hand we typically have a very small
research system which is which is the
software engineering researcher I am
just calling that as a alright and the
relationship is that whatever these guys
do hopefully will produce knowledge that
then
people can use ingenious can tell us
tell the researchers they look this is
the problem we are facing can you help
us so researchers produce output that
researchers themselves consume and build
more research do more exciting work and
researchers also consume knowledge
fundamentally that's the goal which
engineers will consume in software
engineering science is a little
different ball game right so that's one
point that I typically mentioned to
students that it's in some sense a
pyramid structure I've put it in girls
here that you have large number of
Engineers which is creating products
which are even larger number of users so
what 50,000 people in in Microsoft or
20,000 whatever the number is develop
windows and then it's used a millions of
people's large number of users thousands
tens of thousands of engineers coming
down to using knowledge created by
hundreds or maybe a few thousands of
researchers so it's a very you know this
is it's a pyramid structure so if you
want to be in research which is what I
think tekniska is about to excite you to
do some research then you need to be at
this 10 plus you know at this one
percent of the population if you're
excited about it then you should do so
all right so the concern I have to point
this out is that a lot of published
research in software engineering in my
view people can differ in that in my
view does not provide direct help to
engineers it is feeding more on its its
own self okay and so there again the
theme of my talk that crack engaging
with practitioners can really help is I
want to drive home this point that
engaging with engineers through this
particular route all right so this is my
if you wish russom so whetting your
appetite so this portion is done just to
why am I talking about the problem right
so this portion is done so even if you
if you understood good if you're not you
can still catch up on what I'm going to
talk
so now I'm going to tell you a few ways
how you can engage the researcher can
engage with practitioners or how
practitioners can engage in research
alright I'm going to look at two or
three approaches and each one of them
put in one or two experience that I have
in particular right so that's again
platter will show you a range of things
ok so now coming to first which is the
traditional method a lot of researchers
use it get data from projects and then
do all sorts of analysis on data to get
knowledge people use data from companies
people will use data from open source
software lots of papers will be using
data from what practitioners will
produce okay so if you want to do this
this is in fact microsoft research has
very strong groups doing this so i'm
going to give you a few examples that i
myself have used in these are all
published works so i can mention the
name of the company you know easily in
these kinds of things alright so again
the first word this is from my time in
Microsoft was on component testing and
as you'll see none of these works I
could have done myself as a researcher
sitting in my cabin no way so the way
many of these products work that a
product is broken into multiple
components hundreds of components
actually each component has its own team
developing it testing it and so on
certainly two teams are always there a
dev team and a test team and the test
team tests its own component so the goal
we started looking at data where r how
are the bugs being found in these in
these components so we started looking
at that and goal is to understand the
relationship of how testing of other
components helps a component now
remember again I am presenting to you as
if we went in with this
as the goal we were exploring much of it
is reaches retrofitting as 2 i'm giving
you a problem and then explaining the
solution though it was really fast
attacking the problem and figuring it
out and then sort of see that hey look
there is a general think about so the
interesting thing we found was for a
component the defects that were being
found were being found by its own test
team by test team of any other
components by user testing bye-bye
application testing all these are
different methods that that the company
has and we collected data now what's
interesting stuff we found we found that
the maximum number of defects in the
component are not found by its own test
team but by other testings now after he
found it eventually all the people who
said hey look I understand that it's
it's I can understand that so they're
related to do it they understood it but
we started digging further we found
interesting thing that for a component
only a few other components for finding
most of the defense so this is what we
call as test bodies that is for a
component there are bodies body
components which are finding many many
defects in that component right and so
this is the kind of thing God force
components and number of tests bodies
all right someone is taking me and
replaying it back to me perhaps for some
ulterior objective or was it to keep you
to make you silent at least it has had
that effect so so thanks so right so we
found if you see most of the components
have of the order of 10 15 test bodies
even though there are hundreds of
compliments so very interesting thing
came out if you see if you think about
it there are obvious benefits of how you
can do testing so people participated
and they can help themselves use
this data so instead of going out to
hundreds of components they can now go
to ten components five components to
help help their own testing so those who
may be who are into social networks etc
social network of the kind that perhaps
you are participating in you can use the
word buddies components of components
have test buddies so there is actually a
social network getting formed of
components components are making friends
with other components for testing
purposes and you can do interesting
social network analysis if one wishes to
so one example of how we were using data
understanding it working with engineers
to just make sense out of the data a lot
of work which you had to do to reach the
simple charts now let's look at another
another project which we did gain width
with Microsoft again a published work so
interacting with with with many
engineers with product groups what we
found was that when a product is
released let me show you the next slide
this is how the failure rate happened
this is actual data amor tires in a
certain way then you really is a product
do nothing to the product and you find
that failure rate actually decreases
over a period of time this is actually
inconsistent with all software
reliability theory fundamentally
inconsistent all software reliability
theory those of you who might have read
it is called software reliability growth
models which all work under the
assumption that reliability improves as
you remove bugs here nothing is
happening so essentially inconsistent
with existing software reliability model
so this is the data now this is what
practitioners are telling you now what
you do so this this was this is where I
collaborated with the researchers from
Cambridge and then we basically took
this understood it we created a model
and then we use all this data to
to propose a model validated find out
these parameters so interesting model we
said there's something which will decay
it at a certain rate that is steady
state reliability and there is a decay
rate and we were able to tie it with the
existing reliability modern system so so
fair amount of stuff we did validated it
using using all the data you know rich
data that's available and another
interesting concept that we derived that
each product has a stabilization time so
again intuitive most people know about
it you release a product it takes a
little time to stabilize we were able to
sort of put some equations around it and
ensure it there alright so now this is
the first portion that so this is I
guess if I haven't used up what are so
this was the word up so talking about
how you can use data and how you can
actually use the data work with
practitioners and generate useful
knowledge out of it which you can
publish and share with others right so
now I'm going to move on to and I gave
you two examples I have at least three
four others from different companies I
just shared two and and let me now move
on to next step perhaps the small mini
those are that comes in the tally and
this is actually I find this is the most
exciting of opportunity for engaging
with practitioner and certainly perhaps
the most that a practitioner himself can
do if you are a practitioner you can do
some experimentation while you're
practicing to create some knowledge out
of it so experiments if you I'm sure
you've done science experiments in your
school i'm sure you've done it in the
college what happens in an experiment
you control everything you change one
variable or two variables you see some
output and you see how they relate
that's broadly in experimentation
control everything change something and
see how it impacts now experimentation
in software is very very expensive
because building software is a very
expensive game so you can't really do
experiments in software but if you see
projects companies are doing projects
after projects after project thousands
of projects are done by each company
every year so can we use projects as
experiments without without sacrificing
the project goals so that's the
challenge here and what I'm going to
show you that it can easily be with a
little bit of work you can actually
tweak the project a little bit and
generate some useful knowledge out of it
while continuing to do your project okay
so let's take an example from emphasis
and what was in in one of their product
groups they that time this was when I
was there they wanted to use what is
called software inspections and then you
go and he had all these trainers come in
and train all the engineers and how to
do software inspections but when you
talk to the engineers why don't you use
them they will say well it doesn't apply
to us it's a good thing but it doesn't
apply to us so we said hey look this is
a phenomenon called which we call it not
applicable here it's applies to you it
applies to you but it doesn't apply to
me because I'm different my product is
different my project is different and we
are different guys we are you know we do
it differently so what we did was we did
a little experiment in the product
itself said okay you want to do it let's
not take all this publish later let's
get data from your product and see
whether it works for you or not very
simple experiment we push took some
program units we push them one of them
we push them once through inspection we
push them once through unit testing we
collected the data and we analyze it
very simple experiment doesn't then
cause them a few engineers spend maybe a
day extra something like that when we
little extra cost still doing your work
let's make sure cause and you're doing
now playing with doing an experiment k
so there's a whole bunch of knowledge
that came out we showed that inspections
got more
defects we showed that you know some
effort analysis we also showed the
capability of error detection what it
works out the net result after this they
adopted inspection as part of their
product work so to the all these
trainers we would get and they'll say no
we are different we don't want to use it
and we did a small experiment we also
wrote a paper out of it but you did a
small experiment and we find that all
this entire product group actually
started using a little a little example
this i did with sap sap had given me a
project to study global software
engineering and we took a very simple
simple model there is this fair
programming i'm sure some of you would
have heard about it XP agile all these
people talk about pair programming and
we tweak the pair programming and we
said pair programming is supposed to be
two people working together we will
create pairs which will work separately
so we said global pairs is a team of two
people one sitting in India one in u.s.
or whatever in a different opposite time
zone and these two together will be
treated as a single person the project
manager will not know these two
different people he'll say okay I need
to give work here is this wave pair i
will give this work to this except that
since this is now one resource with two
people he treats them as much or
resource as a mega resource which can
work much faster than that so his
project climbing sort of changes
accordingly right so we had a fair
amount of abstraction to keep it simple
to the project manager project manager
doesn't complicate his or her life just
does it just sort of a science work
larger pieces of work to be done every
day but this is good idea you can
discuss it but nobody will buy it so we
with sap we did some actual work and we
did
we saw so we assigned it we tried it on
a project in SAP and one we found some
global pair between India and Germany
and we showed that it actually can
reduce the cycle time substantial of the
work that they were doing ok and let me
take the third one which is probably
going to be the most controversial and
therefore I would like to point out it's
again a work that is getting published
it is it was done in bosch I am NOT an
author I'm not I only held them I'm not
an author of this because as I said
you'll see that this is a touchy
question so what is Parkinson's Law
Parkinson's Law is work expands to fill
the type so if I give you an assignment
you will relate to that better if I give
you a small programming assignment or
some assignment and I give you five
hours you will actually do it in five
hours if I give you two hours you will
probably do this in two hours you can't
if I give you five minutes you find but
so the work will explain because if I
give you five hours you'll relax with
chitchat you will do something and then
you'll take five hours now if you look
in software where the manager gives work
to an engineer and says you will have to
do it in so many hours conceptually the
manager has an interest because the
manager wants everything to be done in
the time that he is projecting so a
manager can theoretically say a look let
me actually give instead of two days let
me get three days so I'm safer because I
know the person will definitely figure
it in three days right so the tendency
of a manager may be to assign more time
than is needed for the world and of
course for all of us look you generally
you give me more time it gives me a
little bit more time to work relax a
little in between so the question these
people wanted to ask is in their
organization is Parkinson's Law at play
very hard a very touchy question so
pleased as I said
very touchy question software engineers
word hated project managers related but
I can imagine in an organization want to
know an answer to that so again you
can't you engage with practitioners I
think these people talk to a lot of
growth explain to them anonymize it to
make sure that the management doesn't
know about the names of people etcetera
etcetera all that stuff was gone proper
messaging etcetera was done but we did
some experiment on 56 projects these
guys day and very simple is there
whatever is the time will reduce it by
one-third but because they had studied
they found a lot of people were not just
goofing off and taking coffee breaks and
so on they were often take a lot of time
was going because a person was waiting
for some information from another person
and so they arranged a 15 minute meeting
every day in the morning to clarify
everything this is like stand-up meeting
since crumb and so on and so forth so
the borrowed ideas from there so reduce
the time by one-third give 15 minutes
for resolving all these things and you
go on to do it so guess what they found
productivity improves by about fifteen
percent so yes full Parkinson's Law is
not at play not the entire thirty-three
percent god same but yes there is there
was some slack an interesting thing they
did that there wasn't any appreciable
change in quality project and and we did
some qualitative feedback also where you
were stressed were you fishing will be
pushing you too hard were you working in
the night etc etc and they generally
found that nobody was saying others
overstressed it's all so interesting
very preliminary very generalizable I
want to put in a word of caution we
ought you know we should sort of say
that software engineers are goofing off
or any such thing there is room for
improving coordination to to improve
productivity which is very important to
companies in our country because they
are mostly in the service business and
productivity the amount of work that
purpose and can do is extremely
important that is this model so what i
will do is i had various examples which
i am going to skip these are all meant
to whet your appetite
that things can be done just being wild
via an engineer few of you can get
together and do some things and and sort
of analyze data do something's there so
the third style approach of how you can
engage it practitioners it just studying
practitioners that's why last point
software engineers actually form a
distinct population which I have a very
separate culture so I talked to some of
my sociologists researchers and in
sociology and organizational behavior
people they have methods of studying
populations to find out what is you know
just just to understand them understand
and so you can support them so what we
started doing was as project again we
started doing was to learn so we started
with this question can we learn from the
guys who are doing very good work
productive people can we learn from them
and find out how are they so productive
and see whether we can transfer that
productivity tools methods to other
people it's like some students are very
effective in studying and if we can
learn from that and pass it on by the
way I did that also in our Institute
just talk to the students found out some
methods and tried to send it to those
other students right so in any case we
started doing this so I will not go in
the details but interesting thing is we
group them into two groups again
anonymize etcetera etcetera all that was
done not so productive productive and
started studying it we would tape them
tape their screens tape that you know
sort of take their logs and all sorts of
stuff and one of the PhD students from
Bosch is actually working on this
problem and finally what to cut it short
what we found was there are indeed
strong similarities in the non
productive people in their own group the
strong similarities in the productive
people and there are the similarities
between them what we haven't had done is
can you transfer this dissimilarities
from the productive group to the less
productive group that's our next step
you haven't yet
alright so what I want to do is to end
here so the main point I wanted to do
point where I there is to drive home is
engaging practitioners is a good route
for doing software engineering research
it may or may not work in non in other
areas said you know etcetera but but
certainly it's a good way to do software
engineering research it will end up
doing perhaps smaller hypotheses than
bigger things that you can do but it's a
very sound way and it can really make
the outcome of this research is almost
directly relevant because you're working
with with researchers with practitioner
so the outcome is directly relevant and
useful now discuss three frameworks for
engaging engaging with practitioners
what practitioners can themselves do and
what really wonderfully if a researcher
in some practitioners get together what
they can do and the last point is really
where I why I think this is an important
thing for in general our community of
software engineers and researchers to
look at is that this is an approach
which i think is very sound for our
power for India because India is large
software engineering population and very
small research population we are
strengths as an engineering software not
in software engineering research that's
where our strength is so so if we can
leverage the practice which is the
biggest thing happening in India then we
can actually use that use that in far
more effective way I found Indian
companies tend to be fairly open about
things they are willing to engage in
such kinds of activities they also have
a very very strong culture of data
collection and measurement something
because it's a younger younger industry
as compared to many other countries they
have established that culture so doing
these kinds of things if you want to do
an experiment in your project collect
data and analyze it far more possible
here and I believe if we actually pursue
this in a larger scale it
lead to a fairly unique kind of
contribution in the software engineering
research which is not that trivalent
because of the way research sort of work
so I think we do that even with a
smaller research base but with the large
engineering base is somehow magically we
can put all of this together in some
ways away we can actually start creating
a niche kind of research area a research
direction and approach in software
interval so that's that's the last slide
I have and I think after this we have
15-20 minutes of Q&A naturalize continue
sending it